[Music]
we used to be watched the I to
everywhere silently recording our every
move
now something is different facial
recognition software can pick out
persons of interest even on a crowded
street problem yes according to this man
the claimant in the first case against
police use of facial recognition which
starts today what had happened I popped
out from my office to go and get a
sandwich at lunchtime and I was walking
down the main pedestrian shopping street
in Cardiff and there was a police van
there there was no signage no police
officers giving out information so by
the time you got close enough to see the
words facial recognition technology on
it you'd already had your your biometric
data scanned and captured and that just
struck me as a sort of fundamental
breach of my my privacy is a law-abiding
citizen nobody at the 2017 Champions
League final gave permission for their
faces to be scanned
but South Wales police did so all the
same
they've been pioneering this technology
on behalf of the government so they have
government funding they've used it on
over 50 occasions so it's a really
important moment to stop and say do we
want this on our streets and we say no
no or yes a decision is urgent the
facial recognition is coming fast so
this 41 camera would be mounted as they
all are on the police officers uniform
this companies put their facial
recognition software in body worn
cameras it picks me up no problem
even 200 meters the reason my face is
being recognized right now is because
I've sent this company my photo but in
the real world the photos will come from
police and counterterrorism so the big
question for civil liberties is not who
makes the technology it's who controls
the database of photos it is a use of
technology the police want to use for
the right reasons they want to help keep
the public safe they want to take bad
guys off the street and that shouldn't
cause anyone any concern who watches the
Watchers the oldest question of justice
needs a new answer for eyes that now
have brains rollin man table Sky News